oi gente tudo bem eu acho que eu tenho
uma missão extremamente importante
porque eu vou falar representando quase
sete mil moradores de uma favela que eu
tive o prazer de conviver por mais de
três anos
a primeira coisa de tudo o que eu
gostaria de dizer é que eu faço pesquisa
dentro da linha de antropologia do
consumo e muita gente se engana quando
pensa que pessoas como eu na minha
formação de mestrado e doutorado
a gente faz pesquisa para que as pessoas
consumam mais mas né que as pessoas
fiquem consumistas e foi muito
interessante porque eu comecei a estudar
antropologia do consumo é me debruçando
sobre os estudos de furto e fraude de
energia elétrica pela chamada nova
classe média que é um termo que eu
detesto mas depois disso eu frequentei
uma série de seminários e foi fruto da
minha dissertação é tema de um outro ted
e aí eu comecei a ver que a mídia de uma
forma geral retratava os fraudadores e
os portadores sempre com a foto de uma
favela do lado e aquilo me incomodou
muito
será que é assim será que de fato as
pessoas fazem gato de energia porque
querem como elas vivem e aí muita gente
pode me acusar me dizer que eu sou uma
uma romântica quando se trata de favela
porque o que eu vou trazer pra vocês é
uma história de afeto é uma história de
empatia e uma história de muita entrega
onde eu morei durante três anos e meio
convive com moradores de uma favela que
não tem vista para a praia que fica na
região portuária do rio de janeiro e é
onde eu aprendi a ser o que eu sou
então a solução pode estar aqui a favela
na vanguarda do consumo colaborativo
a primeira coisa de tudo o que
pode dizer que eu estava lá e era apenas
eu eu estava começando meu trabalho de
campo
aluguei uma quitinete através de
conhecidos e comecei a compartilhar de
uma forma como foi criada né
numa região é de cidade grande onde
todos os valores estão focados na
individualidade é no consumo individual
na forma é pessoal de viver né minha
ferramenta de minhas coisas à minha
roupa minha maquiagem ao meu carro né eu
sou tentou era solteira era só eu no
carro
só que depois de um tempo depois de três
anos e meio convivendo com esses
moradores da favela
eu aprendi na marra a ser nossos e
porque na marra porque o parte de um
choque cultural muito grande
de repente eu estava no lugar que
público e privado têm uma outra
conotação
e como conviver com essas pessoas como
viver nossos é o nome que de uma das
redes sociais da barreira do vasco
as favelas elas se organizam em núcleos
em espécie dia redes sociais por
vizinhança por afinidade por parentescos
então quando você olha favela em si são
várias ilhotas várias pequenas
vizinhanças que se organizam e trocam
entre si e se protegem 2 de todas as
dificuldades do mundo e por aí vai ser
nossos é fazer parte de uma rede social
de assistência mútua é você ter um baús
é como se fosse
imagina um trapezista e você sabe que
tem uma rede em baixo dos seus pés para
te proteger na hora que você mais
precisa
só que pra isso compartilhar e colaborar
faz parte de um estilo de vida e isso
foi uma coisa que eu aprendi na marra é
que a favela não pode ser explicada
apenas pelo fi pela questão pela
característica das suas mazelas daí
suficiência da precariedade a a favela é
muito mais do que isso é e mais uma vez
eu não tô sendo romântica eu morava em
cima de um esgoto ou muitas vezes a
minha resistência do chuveiro queimava e
eu tinha que tomar banho na casa dos
meus vizinhos por muitas vezes eram
barulho com muitas vezes era polícia por
muitas vezes eram os meninos do tráfico
muitas vezes era a própria briga
existem os problemas da favela é isso é
inegável o problema todo é que a gente
só sabe isso e eu achava que a favela
tem um contexto a favela é cidade
afastar a favela tem uma cultura ela não
é só precária e ela tem algo dentro dela
que traduz confiança e oferece segurança
eu me sentia segura dentro da rede do
nossos sendo parte desses nossos eu tive
que viver com uma outra dinâmica e uma
outra esfera sócio cultural que a
reciprocidade na esfera íntima no
bastava simplesmente ser eu
eu tinha que compartilhar eu tinha que
ser alguém ter uma integrante que
fizesse sentido para aquele grupo
o coletivo sempre se sobrepõe a um
indivíduo e aí eu acho que é uma coisa
bem interessante da gente falar que é o
seguinte
agora tá muito modismo é falar de
colaboração compartilhamento vamos todos
dividir é o meu prédio todo mundo de
vídeos eletrodomésticos né tem um monte
de
eu acho que essas políticas amb
a ubi eu acho que são até políticas
muito bem bem intencionados
só que o valor não se impõe valor nasce
com a brota com a gente aposta vocês
vocês experimentar em qualquer outro
deste tipo de rede de troca e aí você
empresta uma sanduicheira aí um belo dia
sanduicheira volta queimada e aí você
vai tentar tratar com aquela pessoa com
a qual você prestou next e fez a troca
aí ele fala não comigo funcionou
aí o que você faz você faz igual àquele
menino mimado do do sol do futebol de
várzea
você bota a situação do cheiro debaixo
do braço diz não quero mais brincar
disso não porque existe mazela existe
briga na favela
sim existe essa história de que olha
quebrou mas o risco existe mas chega uma
hora que ele olha para o que ele tem
intuito incentivar mente ele diz assim
não mas eu não vou arrumar briga com
fulano porque naquele outro dia ele me
ajudou porque naquele outro dia ele pode
me ajudar
então é algo que este é uma espécie de
regra social é uma regra tácita isso não
é dito então essa liberdade para
emprestar ou tomar algo de alguém né
é é algo que não é imposto é quase
natural eu só não digo que é natural
porque eu sou entrou paulo é cultura
obviamente mas é algo que é tá tão naná
está tão arraigado tatão no ser daquele
daquele grupo que eles nem percebem que
eles são assim então trocas empréstimos
doações cuidados colaborações se ocorrem
dentro daquela rede de assistência mútua
e também fora dela e leva tempo para
você se aceito na rede eu levei cerca de
três anos até ficar íntima até o
participar até eu ficar amiga até criar
um vínculo de confiança até eu
participar de vários eventos e criar uma
historicidade nós precisamos voltar a
nos conectar com os próximos a seus
vizinhos não se falam mais
as pessoas quase se esbarram e não se
falam às vezes as pessoas têm até não
tem nada contra as redes sociais mas às
vezes nós temos mais intimidade com quem
a gente não vê do que com a gente vê lá
na favela é assim o virtual eo
presencial ele está integrado né então
juntos já que eu já estava acostumado
cotada na rede dos nossos e eu fui
contada de uma forma muito interessante
porque depois de três anos e meio lá eu
queria comemorar meu aniversário eu
estava com muita saudade das pessoas
ou eu falei vou fazer meu aniversário na
favela os meus amigos queriam conhecer a
barreira do vasco porque onde eu vou a
barreira do vasco ficar famosa
e eu falei vou fazer um aniversário e
liguei pra vânia vânia rodrigues
presidente da associação uma das minhas
melhores amigas
eu falei vaninha chama o pessoal para o
adversário é o pessoal quem os nossos
quando ela falou os nossos
eu percebi que ela não estava dizendo
dela ela tá falando ela estava incluindo
e quando ela me incluiu aquilo me
impactou foi para aí alto lá e é isso
mexe com a cabeça de todo um protocolo
que está fazendo pesquisa de campo gente
espera aí eu não sofri da favela eu não
sou morador ou não aparento ser da
favela há como eu sou nossos porque eu
sou nossos então já que eu era nosso
savani linha começou a procurar casa e
eu fui morar no beco no beco onde todos
moravam desse grupo dela chamado beco
eunice rodrigues
então eu fui lá e comecei a conviver no
beco então no beco a gente como a gente
dança gente ver tv
a gente faz churrasco quinho a gente faz
festa para a criança no beco ao ponto de
encontro no b conquistou uma cerveja
sentada na guia dada por do portão até
mais tarde e é meio tudo muito junto e
misturado é é um pouco entrar na casa do
outro é são as frequenta ações ea janela
aberta a porta aberta é você está sempre
pronto para receber e para freqüentar o
outro e eu nunca tinha vivido isso
talvez no interior do brasil a gente
ainda tenha essa essa espécie de
vilarejo essa idéia da vizinhança nas
cidades menores mas numa cidade grande
verticalizada de onde eu vim
isso é praticamente impossível eu fiquei
encantada eu fui afetado por esse campo
e eu comecei a olhar a favela como uma
cidade pequena onde várias trocas
aconteciam e eu fazia parte dessa troca
então a rede social por exemplo ela
prepara a festa da associação de
moradores festa das crianças festa das
mães dia dos pais natal então a gente de
alguma maneira cada um contribuir com
que sabia fazer e eu estava lá tirando
foto
e só entende a rede quando se faz parte
dela
você não tem consciência do que é uma
rede até você ser cotada por uma é algo
tão visceral é algo tão importante e é
como se fosse um brilhante uma jóia que
você está fazendo parte e essa rede hoje
por exemplo ela está no bolso no meu
bolso no meu celular numa um grupo de
what's up que eu fui convidada chamada
família
então é esse mesmo sentimento com
famílias e parentes próximos
ele se revela nas redes sociais de
assistência mútua nas favelas não se diz
não para a rede porque um dia você pode
precisar dela e quando é que você vai
saber disso ser da rede não é uma
escolha ele é um valor e é pra sempre e
eu posso dizer que é tão forte como uma
relação consangüínea o modo de viver
dessa maneira ela está ligada à
abundância coletiva eu sou feliz quando
o outro está feliz a gente se reconhece
nas nossas tristezas nas mazelas nas
dificuldades
a gente tenta tirar o peso de um deles
né do de alguém que esteja passando por
uma dificuldade financeira ou doméstica
a gente aconselha se alguém morre todo
mundo vai ajudar então é um é um jeito
muito a acolhedor de viver e eu nunca
imaginei que fosse contra isso num lugar
onde todos os jornais toda tv
toda a imprensa me dizia que era
perigoso violento criminoso marginal e
eu encontrei exatamente isso numa favela
e aí o que se compartilha o que é
dividido porque eu comecei a falar se
gente sempre está tudo aqui né
aí eu vi o utensílio doméstico e aí tem
uma história muito legal com a
pipoqueira quer pipoqueira da silvia ea
vaninha juntava com ela tem um filho que
é o joão miguel juntava um monte de
crianças no beco e a vânia chegava e
falava faz a filha mais velha vai lá e
pega as apega a pipoqueira da silvia
voltava a falar gente eu fiz ver isso
acontecendo mas assim dezenas de vezes
ao longo desses três anos e meio
um dia o embarque ficar ficar
questionando telefone
se no campo porque era fica sempre
pegando a pipoqueira do outro a lógica
individualista né de fora ela virou
falou assim botou a mão nas cadeiras e
disse elaine
olha o tamanho da minha cozinha william
se eu comprar tudo o que eu preciso quem
vai morar na minha casa são as coisas e
não as pessoas
e aí qual é a cara da antropólogos a
pesquisadora e doutoranda da
universidade federal fluminense fica no
chão né
eu falei gente já está me ensinando a
ser sustentável
olha isso e aí eu comecei a prestar
atenção que sustentar eu comecei a fazer
prova né do tipo será que é isso mesmo
a primeira coisa que eu fiz eu não
comprei um fogão quando tinha fogão e
pergunta onde é que é um sav onde é que
sejam tal foi na casa dos outros e eu
ainda a escolha é simone hoje tem o que
é dona eunice hoje eu fiz um peixe
inclusive fase o peixe pra mim
ai eu falei eu tô com vontade de comer
um peixe mamãe foi lá fora nomes de 85
anos mamãe foi lá fora comprar um peixe
pra você fez com pirão então era toda
essa rede de afeto que eu nunca tinha
tido era filha do apartamento eu nunca
tinha tido contato e eu encontrei numa
favela à internet serviços para
instalação e manutenção
aí lembra do gato de energia o gato de
internet o gato de tv que eu fui estudar
lá no mestrado
pois é lá na favela não é gato é
compartilhamento é outra lógica nessa
compra lá wifi bota wifi dividir
contrata velo dividir pelo valor todo
mundo paga um pouquinho a mesma conexão
chama sky pago pacote premium onta
direita 45 pontos cada um de vídeo ponto
isso é inteligência e isso é
inteligência isso não é enganação isso é
jeitinho nelo sentido é crítico da
palavra
a gente tem acesso à eletricidade a água
ea outros bens e serviços produtos
locais onde você tem preço amigo nessa
cobra mais barato eletrodomésticos e se
equivale a até falou assim para mim
uma beleza faz frango de padaria mas
você não só pode usar aqui na barreira
aí eu porque só pode usar aqui na
barreira porque puxa muita luz
o pé de galinha da dona eunice e é muito
legal porque esse pé de galinha não é só
um pé de galinha pé de galinha é o bolo
da claudia é a feijoada da cristina
cada pessoa tem uma expertise do saber
fazer e na hora da festa na hora da da
convivência na hora do da sociabilidade
cada um contribui com aquilo que sabe
fazer então é esperar 15
a gente tem produtos e e roupa roupa de
festa maquiagem eu eu usei a a a toalha
e quando eu tive fiquei sem energia
elétrica
dodô ele fiquei sem resistência no
chuveiro
o andrade falou assim eu falei andrada e
eu já estava no local né
andrade gritava que o povo alegre a
andar
olha só chover que é boa ele falou sobe
bem tomar banho em cima
eu falei para ele que eu vou pegar minha
toalha ele não tem toalha aqui
aí eu falei então tá então assim é isso
né então usa toalha nossa que tem que
ter sabor de tudo aqui falei tá bom
então público e privado ganhar outra
dinâmica
o uso dos espaços comuns a rua é o
quintal da casa né serviço do quer do
cuidado de idosos rezadeira cuidado de
criança eu acho incrível porque você
pode ter creche por um dia ou por um
período
então você pois que tem filho você
coloca criança e paga uma fortuna de
creche muitas vezes né
então lá na favela você pode ir lá falar
então olha eu só tenho 20 reais dá para
dar uma olhada no fulano aqui para
esconder néscio e aí pronto da jeito
tudo dá um jeito
tudo dá certo a mudança eu fiz três
mudanças né
eu nunca paguei ninguém eu sou eu
colocando o saco na frente da casa
passava alguém dizer a amizade ajuda foi
todo para a rua alzira vaga lá do outro
lado que a pessoa carrega uma coisa não
sei nem sei quem é a pessoa não sei
carregavam né então a favela possui
caráter
iscas deste moderno consumo colaborativo
mesmo que os moradores não atente para
isso
isso é o mais legal a agente e aí eu
acho que reside a magia primeira coisa
de tudo o que a favela tem que faz com
que as pessoas ajam dessa forma em outra
coisa qual é a lição que a favela tem
para nos ensinar
então a barreira do vasco ela apresenta
práticas que apesar de informais e que
não estejam legitimados pelas
instituições elas estão afinados com a
vanguarda do pensamento social e
econômico contemporâneo
eles são colaborativo e eles são a eles
têm uma economia de compartilhamento e
sabe por quê
porque aqui é assim todas as vezes que
eu perguntei pra vaninha e é isso que
vocês são assim porque isso acontece
dessa maneira ela responde porque aqui é
assim simples aqui é assim não é que
assim então é a resposta que eles sempre
me deram e eu queria agradecer a
barreira do vasco pela incrível
experiência que eu tive é foi um divisor
de águas na minha vida nada será como
antes
e essa palestra cyted em homenagem à
dona eunice que nos deixou no passado
que a minha principal interlocutor a
minha rezadeira a minha companhia do dia
a dia com quem eu comia pirão de peixe e
via televisão é tv
ah eu queria deixar um recado final essa
é a parede da casa da dona eunice que
foi pintada por uma das duas
adolescentes da favela onde tem se dizer
lutar sempre desistir jamais
é eu queria deixar só o pedido é para
ele ficar copiando é políticas públicas
de fora
parem de olhar para a europa parem de
olhar para a noruega para a dinamarca
parem de olhar para modelos de negócios
mirabolantes do do vale do silício parem
a resposta está mais perto do que você
imagina
basta a gente sabe olhar as pessoas com
a lente certa
acho que é isso obrigada